نحن نقف الان في منطقه تل الزعتر شرق مخيم
جباليا شمال قطاع غزه هذه المنطقه التي
كانت تتوغل بها قوات الاحتلال واليات
الاحتلال حيث دمرت جميع المنازل في هذه
المنطقه ودمرت ايضا المسجد الرئيسي لهذه
المنطقه وجميع ابار المياه هنا وايضا
البنيه التحتيه لهذه المنطقه تم تدميرها
بالكامل حيث ان هذه المنطقه تعتبر من اكثر
الاماكن المرتفعه هنا في شمال قطاع غزه
هنا كانت تمركز اليات الاحتلال وقوات
الاحتلال في هذا
المكان هذا المسجد هو مسجد البشير تم
تدميره بالكامل ايضا تم تدمير بجانب
المسجد روضه الاطفال وايضا تم تدمير بجانب
الروضه هنا كما نشاهد في هذه الصوره هذا
حوز المياه وهو بئر المياه المغذي لجميع
منازل المواطنين في هذه المنطقه منطقه تل
الزعتر كانت منطقه عامره
بالسكان امنه مطمئنه دخلوها الاحتلال
دخلها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي دمر عشرات
المنازل منها بعد ان نفذ عشرات الغارات
الجويه والاحزمه الناريه فيها حتى انه
المعلم الاساسي في المنطقه مسجد حسن شراب
مسجد البشير
سابقا تم تدميره في العام 2014 اي حوز
الميه اللي بغذي منطقه الزعتر ومعسكر
جباليه وبغي منطقه السكه ومنطقه زايد تم
تدميره بشكل كامل البنيه التحتيه في
المنطقه لم تسلم من اليات الاحتلال
والدمار حتى انه المجاري
والمياه شبكات المياه كلها دمرت عن بكره
ابيها لم يبقى منها شيء اي الناس قاعده
بترجع لدورها
اي للاسف اي من الناس تفاجا انه داره
رايحه ومنهم تفاجا انه داره غير صالحه
للسكن ومع ذلك الناس مص مصممين على انهم
يرجعوا لدورهم وعلى بيوتهم وحتى لو لم
يجدوا اي شيء نقف الان هنا في شوارع منطقه
تل الزعتر هذه المنطقه التي دار فيها
المعارك بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال واستمرت لايام بل لاسابيع في هذه
المنطقه نشاهد حجم هذا الدمار في المكان
دمار كبير للمنازل وللشوق ولبنيه التحتيه
من قبل قوات الاحتلال ايضا هنا كما نشاهد
اثار المعارك في هذا المكان ك نشاهد هنا
بقايا من اليه الاحتلال التي تم تفجيرها
في هذا المكان من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
المنطقه الان اصبحت غير صالحه للسكن
نهائيا بسبب هذا الدمار الذي حل بها طبعا
ما زالت قوات الاحتلال تقوم بالقاء عدد من
قذائف المدفعيه واطلاق النار على كل من
يحاول الاقتراب من هذه المنطقه او الوصول
لهذا المكان او محاوله السكن في المنازل
التي تصلح للاستقرار اذا هكذا هو المشهد
هنا في منطقه تل الزعتر التي شهدت معارك
ضاريه بين المقاومه وقوات الاحتلال وايضا
شهدت قصف عنيف خلال توغل قوات الاحتلال في
هذا المكان حيث الاحتلال دمر كل ما يصلح
للسكن او للاستقرار في هذه المنطقه وما
زال حتى اللحظه يقوم باطلاق القذائف
واطلاق النار على منازل المواطنين انس
الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه